acá sobra algo mejor que el orden y la
limpieza
para mí no hay casi nada mejor
recuerdo cuando era chico y aún más
chico
recuerdo cuando estaba en la primaria
estábamos en un partido de basquetbol
mis compañeros conmigo y en un momento y
metí canasta mis amigos se acercan me
cargan y cuando ellos me cargan
yo puse mi brazo detrás de la cabeza de
mis compañeros
mi yo de nueve años cuando sienten su
brazo embarrado todo su sudor
escurriendo brilloso
millón de ocho años le desagradó tanto
que hace que para debajo
voy a ir al baño inmediatamente a
lavarme todo el brazo
cuando estaba en la secundaria estaba en
un receso con un compañero y sin pedirme
solo le dio un sorbo a la bebida que yo
traía
yo yo lo único que hice fue abrir mucho
los ojos y decirle te lo regalo quedate
la provecho
estas cosas a veces me pasaban y yo sólo
sabía que no iba a ayunar lo mismo no
pasa nada en la prepa comenzó esta etapa
de salir de fiesta y la pasábamos
increíble por más tarde que yo llegara a
mi casa 2 de la mañana 3 de la mañana y
por más cansado que estuviera me tenía
que meter a bañar para poderme dormir
a veces lo intentaba de que no me voy a
bañar no podía
pero todo esto siempre estuvo conectado
con altos niveles de ansiedad
tanto empezó a aumentar mi ansiedad que
terminé en urgencias por problemas del
corazón
problemas del corazón a tus 20 años no
es algo que no considere normal
después de varios estudios con
cardiólogos internistas yo ya estaba
harto cual creen que fue mi diagnóstico
trastorno obsesivo compulsivo
o tok
pero a ver qué hace el trastorno
obsesivo-compulsivo se los voy a
explicar con lo que a mí me sucedía
el trastorno obsesivo compulsivo es la
cadena de pensamientos no deseados o
situaciones en la cabeza no deseadas
pensar que todo está sucio y que yo
estoy sucio y es desagradable esas
sensaciones
eso es la obsesión
y la obsesión genera comportamientos
repetitivos lavarme las manos cada vez
que puedo meterme a bañar cuando me
despierto antes de dormir y si voy al
gimnasio sé lo que estarán pensando yo
con el cob y soy feliz cuando los
protocolos que ponte gel anti bacterial
tú también tratamiento también checa te
la temperatura
y yo soy feliz con eso
y si vas a una plaza se te queman las
manos de tanto gel
esto como les digo siempre estuvo
conectado con altos niveles de ansiedad
y eso es la obsesión los comportamientos
repetitivos eso es la compulsión los
comportamientos repetitivos provocados
por la obsesión
a ver yo ya sabía que tenía pero ahora
tenía que saber cómo ayudarme para uno
empezar a ayudarse en este tipo de
trastornos tiene que descubrir y
recordar en qué momentos de su vida
su problema a dejar ser una prioridad
estresante
así que comencé comenzó a pensar cuando
es que me ha dejado de importar el tema
del orden y de la limpieza
y en uno de esos recuerdos me bienestar
la mente
en una labor social aislada de la
comunidad de la ciudad
nos tocó hacer una obra con integrantes
del grupo de la comunidad
para este momento en el último momento
empezar la obra cambiaron el papel que
yo iba a interpretar
una niña tenía que escoger a alguien de
la comunidad escogió alberto excelente
persona alberto él es un sembrador de la
comunidad que llevaba siete horas bajo
el sol
trabajando antes de venirse a la hora
lo que a mí me tocó hacer
quitarle el zapato
quitarle el calcetín
y luego lavarle su pie con agua y con
jabón con mis manos y después darle un
beso
yo yo tenía que lavarle el pie alberto
para esto ya llevábamos siete días en
esa comunidad ayudando al día tras día
noche tras noche yo me sentía tan tan
lleno de felicidad y de alegría de poder
estar ayudando a los que cuando llegó el
momento lo hice y no me puse a pensar en
lo desagradable que podría ser para mí o
en lo incómodo que normalmente sería
para mí
y ahí fue cuando
me di cuenta cuando es que mi trastorno
deja de ser una prioridad estresante
cuando estoy sirviendo a los demás
cuando estoy ayudando al prójimo
y en uno de esos recuerdos me acordé de
otra historia
valeria es una señorita con él con
anorexia grave otro trastorno
cuando valeria se entera que está
embarazada sufre un colapso nervioso por
el miedo de matar a su bebé por no comer
bien
durante los nueve meses valeria conmigo
de manera excelente y su hija nació con
perfecta salud
y le preguntaron valeria si desde la
adolescencia tiene esa anorexia se verá
cómo lograste verte gorda nueve meses y
ella dijo lo siguiente mi trastorno es
algo con lo que voy a vivir toda mi vida
pero a mi bebé es lo primero y voy a
hacer lo que sea por ella
y ahí es cuando se ve que a ella le pasó
lo mismo cuando ayudó a alguien más fue
cuando lo supero durante esos nueve
meses volvió a ser anoréxica pero
durante ayuda durante la ayuda ella se
olvidó por completo de eso su cerebro lo
apagó
y esto no son sólo testimonios esto está
comprobado en la universidad
northwestern medical school dirigida por
el neurocientífico jordan grafman
se centró en por quedar
estimular los centros de recompensa del
cerebro y le pregunto a los voluntarios
si estarían dispuestos a ayudar a
órganos a organizaciones benéficas
específicas el estudio descubrió que al
momento de servir el centro de
recompensa del cerebro se iluminaba
en otra universidad en la universidad
carnegie mellon dirigida por la otra
neurocientífica vez mcchrystal
le pregunta a los voluntarios si
estarían dispuestos a ayudar cuatro
horas a la semana a organizaciones
benéficas
ellos descubrieron en sus estudios que
disminuye la presión arterial en adultos
mayores que disminuyen los niveles de
cortisol en los adolescentes el cortisol
es el encargado que produce el estrés
y que aumenta el soporte al dolor ya que
produce un mayor nivel de oxitocina en
el cerebro que es la encargada de
reducir la ansiedad y el estrés
y con todo esto
yo te pregunto cómo vas con tu top
como vas con tu toque porque no sé si lo
sabían pero todos aquí tenemos
comportamientos obsesivos
quiero que me levanten la mano quien
desconocía de este tema o no piensa que
tiene algún tipo de comportamiento
obsesivo
ok 1 2 3 algunos más bueno les voy a
decir los comportamientos obsesivos más
comunes que tenemos tal vez todos los
días muchos de nosotros uno
acumulación
si esa caja de amazon que compraste en
internet un producto y la caja la
guardas porque está en perfecto estado
como para tirarla y ahí se está como la
encaja con las botellas de vino vacías
que tu papá acumula y pues ahí se quedan
comprobación si serra el coche no no sé
el coche no y sabes que a los 15
segundos automáticamente se vuelve a
cerrar pero te quedas con el nervio
una satisfacción y tranquilidad por la
simetría estás en tu área trabajo en tu
escritorio pero ese lápiz tiene que
estar bien acomodado la niña los
plumones no saben pero es obsesiva
mucho
pero por el tema estético
ahora quiero que levante la mano quien
se sintió identificado con alguno de
estos comportamientos obsesivos
la cosa cambia
no soy el único
todos tenemos cierto nivel de estrés
cierto nivel de ansiedad en grande o
pequeña medida
cuando tú sirves a los demás de una
manera incondicional el amor prevalece y
le gana a todo
el amor por la ayuda al otro le gana a
todo
si tú
tienes algún problema ponte a servir
deja de concentrarte en ti por unos
momentos y ayuda a quien más lo necesita
si has de tener toques que sea de amor
[Aplausos]